don't be scared of me you're looking
away like I'm gonna do something I'm not
I'm a huge fan
I'm uh come on oh no quick Liza let's
just get ya know I love it I love it
ready hit it
shaking my arm all right I think we got
it thank you so much thank you good PETA
Lapita you didn't have some pizza
okay here's what I'm gonna do you're not
all right
Merrill here's my idea okay so you are
nominated
it's a record-breaking 18 times right so
I thought we would try to break another
record right now with the most retweets
of a photo so right now I'm gonna take a
picture of us and then we'll see if we
can break the record for the most
retweets and then yeah you two get in
here - Julia putting in tanning if you
can get in also candy Bradley we come
down a minute
Jennifer come in also Brad get in here
no I'm doing
[Applause]
maril can you take it I can't get
everybody in here I got this are you in
here wait a second okay all right I
think we have it what did you get in on
that - God Europe
total hog
[Applause]